[Music]
[Applause]
just ask yourself these questions do you
always feel bloated after eating do you
feel sluggish or heavy after a meal do
you generally feel uncomfortable if you
answer yes to most of them well you have
been eating your meals wrong what do i
mean by that the truth is many of us do
feel discomfort bloated and sluggish
after a meal and we think that it's
normal but in fact this is not normal
when you eat your meals correctly you
should feel energized instead of
sluggish did you know that digesting
food requires more energy than any other
functions in the human body hence when
your body's digestive system isn't
functioning at its optimum it affects
our entire being we want to be able to
digest food as quick and efficient as
possible let me share something with you
that could potentially change the way
you eat and feel it is the principle of
food combining
food combining is a little known secret
for promoting gut health and to improve
your digestion this provides your body
with the right feel and energy and can
also help you lose weight so as much as
i can i have been following these
principles and they have helped with my
gut health tremendously so the idea
behind food combining is that certain
foods pair well together while others do
not as different foods digest at
different rates in our body and require
different digestive environments so food
combining refers to eating or not eating
certain foods together in the same
sitting in order to achieve optimal
digestion this principle is not about
restricting food itself but rather it is
the awareness of knowing how to choose
and what to eat in a single meal now
before we get into the guidelines of
food combining let's first understand
how digestion works in our body let's
talk about acid and alkaline enzymes
which are responsible to eat our body to
digest the food we eat let's take a look
at protein versus carbs protein requires
an acidic environment to digest with
acidic digestive enzymes whereas cups
requires an alkaline environment with
alkaline enzymes your typical diet pairs
meat and starch in one meal for example
you might enjoy a piece of steak
together with potatoes or
chicken with rice protein and cups have
opposite digestive requirements and
eating them together causes your body to
release both acid and alkaline solutions
the acid and alkaline solutions will
neutralize each other which can slow
digestion and cause post meal
sluggishness or bloating this is because
your body is using more energy digesting
than needed hence understanding food
combining principles can help support
the health of your entire gut here are
five really simple principles first do
not combine protein with starch in a
meal as you know now in order to be
digested protein needs an acidic
environment which is why it is
considered a bad combination to eat
protein with starch in a meal instead
consume protein with non-starchy
vegetables such as leafy greens broccoli
cauliflower
carrots cabbage cucumber celery bell
peppers onions and more these vegetables
are rich in their own enzymes hence they
don't need an alkaline environment for
digestion and because of that they won't
interfere with the acidic environment
required by protein this principle also
applies to plant proteins such as beans
and legumes so here's what a good
combination would look like
while salmon with broccoli and carrots
chicken with kale and cauliflower
tofu with bell peppers onions and celery
second pear starch with healthy fats and
non-starchy vegetables starches such as
brown rice quinoa barley along with
starchy vegetables such as sweet potato
corn and squash need an alkaline
environment for digestion so this is
what a good food combination would look
like
baked potato with avocado and stir-fried
vegetables quinoa and pumpkin with nuts
and seeds and leafy greens and cherry
tomatoes brown rice and stir-fried
vegetables cooked with coconut oil by
now you should know that leafy greens
and non-starchy vegetables go well with
everything they contain their own
digestive enzymes hence can be paired
with any food without causing a traffic
jam in your gi tract if you're totally
confused with the food combining rules
to keep it simple simply choose a single
macronutrient whether it's protein
starch or healthy fats with leafy greens
or non-starchy vegetables it is as easy
as that the next principle eat fruits
alone fruit is a simple sugar that
digests very rapidly in roughly 20 to 30
minutes whereas protein for example can
take between three to four hours to
digest now if you combine fruits and
protein in a single meal it can create
chaos in your gi tract because of the
different time needed for the food to be
digested that is why it is also best to
avoid eating fruits right after meals
since fruits digest faster than any
other food they are best to be eaten
alone so that they do not have the
chance to ferment as i've mentioned
earlier fermentation in your gi tract
will make you feel bloated and gassy so
it is best to consume fruits alone the
final important guideline is to avoid
drinking water together with your meals
water can dilute your digestive fluids
which can slow down digestion now before
knowing this i used to drink lots of
water with my meals and would feel
extremely bloated and even experience
stomach pain if you really need to have
small sips of water with your meals and
try to drink most of your water away
from your meals you can also aid your
digestion by drinking lemon water
roughly 20 to 30 minutes before a meal
lemon contains ascorbic acid which can
help stimulate digestion i drink lemon
water on an empty stomach first thing in
the morning now there really isn't
enough scientific research to back the
food combining principles but the reason
why i'm sharing this with you is because
it has worked for me i'm someone who has
an extremely sensitive gut and even a
small trigger can cause me to feel
bloated gassy constipated and experience
extreme stomach discomfort the goal of
food combining is to improve your
digestion to increase your energy levels
improve absorption of nutrients and it
can also help with weight loss should
you try this the next time you
experience digestive distress just take
a look at your plate and see if you're
combining the wrong foods together try
to apply these principles and start to
take note on how your body reacts and
feels
this might just be the magical solution
to a healthy well-being be sure to share
this video on to someone who might learn
from this like this video and don't
forget to subscribe to my youtube
channel for a lot more fitness tips
workout videos and also recipes do turn
on your notification button so that you
will get notified every time i share a
new video let me know how you get on and
if you're combining the right foods into
your diet all the best